you have to be you have to be vulnerable
to your female partner because female
long-term sex drive is based on
emotional intimacy
so you have to have some vulnerability
with your female partner
if you are not vulnerable to her at all
you are sending the message to her that
she is immediately replaceable that you
are not investing in her and that she
should not have sex with you
that's the message you're sending now
how do you be vulnerable to her because
men with attachment issues
again men with attachment issues think
that being vulnerable to her means
throwing himself at her feet
sobbing uncontrollably telling her how
miserable he is
and then begging her to please have sex
with him while he's crying
that's what they think i say when they
should be vulnerable
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
on episode 92
i'm joined by adam smith adam lane smith
is a licensed psychotherapist and author
known as the prometheus on twitter he
works primarily with patients who have
extreme attachment
and generational attachment dysfunctions
he also does work with people
experiencing prtsd
and trauma this was a fantastic episode
i didn't even come close to asking adam
all the questions i had for him
we spoke about resolving attachment
issues in relationships
we talked about what attachment issues
might look like
and how to solve them adam spoke about
marriage divorce
differences in male and female
communication and differences
in male and female expectations in
committed partnerships
i want him on again this episode was so
full of interesting information on
potentially
screwed up relationships subscribe if
you enjoy this content
speaking of relationships and how to
potentially improve them
this episode is sponsored by orate a
super high quality jewelry company store
i love i wear these minimalist
rings that i'm obsessed with this one's
less minimalist
but they have really high quality gold
pieces range from classic to statement
to completely original
i wear these stackable rings on my
thumbs all the time
and pinky and ring finger orates gold is
solid
and i'm someone who's allergic to any
type of low quality metal or people or
even gold that isn't high quality
enough carrot orate has beautiful rings
and necklaces and diamonds and really
cute earrings as well
because it's real gold people can wear
it and never have to take it off
shower sport sleep cook whatever like i
said i don't remove
mine so i don't lose them all
or 8 pieces come with a lifetime
warranty as well
or it was started by two friends during
brunch when one got a green finger from
an overpriced ring
sparking a conversation about how they
were fed up with the traditional jewelry
market
don't buy your girlfriends or wife
something that turns their finger green
and for dudes if you want ideas their
mini gold bar earrings are cute
and any of these stackable rings you can
go back multiple times the same website
you don't need to come up with new ideas
for gifts
because they have a ton of different
options that match each other
for fifteen percent off you can learn
how to spell my name
for fifteen percent off your first orate
purchase go to a
u r a t e newyork.com
michaela and use promo code michaela
again for fifteen percent off your first
orate purchase go to oratenewyork.com
michaela and use promo code michaela i
hope you enjoy this episode
adam smith welcome to my podcast thank
you it's nice to be here
okay so i saw you on modern wisdom
and i saw your twitter thread and then i
started following you you have a very
interesting twitter
so could we could we just start off or
could you just start off by giving
uh people who don't know you a brief
background about who you are and what
you do
sure so i am a licensed psychotherapist
by trade and i always tell everyone
everything i say is not healthcare
advice if you think you have a problem
go see a professional don't listen to me
but i have um i've worked as a
psychotherapist for a long time i did
the correctional facility out in
california
a san joaquin correction facility for
guys facing the death penalty for severe
crimes
doing therapy for them um i moved out
here to the midwest and i work with a
lot of low-income families
doing a lot of work i'm just trying to
repair families generational brokenness
attachment problems
attachment is one of my two major
specialties especially generational
attachment as it's broken down here in
the west over the last hundred years
it's one of my clinical focuses my other
is post traumatic stress disorder and
traumas
i typically when i work in a clinic i
get handed the most severe trauma cases
because they think that i can handle it
and i love working with that population
i also write books i've written
something like
last tally probably 20 books now so okay
a lot of things out there okay great
this is going to be good because
i feel like i suffer from many of those
problems so this should be an
interesting conversation
can we can we start off before we get
into it
can you tell me what an attachment issue
looks like
absolutely so most people have no idea
what attachment is and it really
is the fundamental way that one human
being connects to another human being
and that's based on
everything that happens to us from birth
through childhood
everything when we're small our brain
says that everything that happens to me
is my fault
and some of us grow out of that most of
us don't
but the little brain if someone neglects
you if someone doesn't pay attention to
you if someone hurts you
abuses you if mom is gone 10 hours a day
and you're in the care of strangers that
maybe the baby doesn't smell a similar
family member
um maybe the baby is competing for
attention with 10 other kids
whatever it might be the brain learns
that other people
don't want them around there must be
something wrong with me that is making
people abandon me or hit me or hurt me
and what happens is the brain says there
must be something wrong
with me deep down inside that everyone
else can see
but i can't i don't know what's wrong
with me but anyone who sees this thing
they abandon me and reject me so i need
to put up a wall and never show anybody
what secretly
really inside of me and i'll just live
my life that way
and so we we act like cardboard cutouts
to other people
we don't share our needs with people we
do ten nice things for them hoping
they'll figure out what we secretly want
on the inside but we can never show
it that's what attachment is it's that
insecure connection that tells you
no one else is really going to want to
put up with you or help you
or be close to you and if they ever
learn who you really are on the inside
they will reject you just as badly as
everyone else did in childhood
that's attachment okay when you say
babies like left with other with
strangers what age are you talking about
birth anything um attachment seems like
it goes up to maybe
10 12 once we start getting a little bit
more ability to reason
we can start saying okay some of these
things happen because of other events
but it's strange many adults don't even
apply that logic back to
age five age seven i've worked with
people who go into daycare
and are okay i've worked with people who
go into daycare and that is one of the
fundamental shifts in their attachment
it can depend on the quality of the
daycare it especially depends if you're
with family
if your grandmother watches you it seems
to be a lot less detrimental than if
some stranger
watches you um the research is out on
exactly
how dangerous those are that daycare can
be
for those children but the research is
pretty consistent that there
tends to be at least tends to be more
anxiety outcomes more mental health
outcomes more negative mental
outcomes associated with that daycare
it's not popular to talk about
people go after you pretty viciously for
it but it seems like it's having a
shaping effect
well i'm not that surprised actually
because
especially some daycares like
you wouldn't want to put a kid in there
and then actually watch the daycare
all day correct yeah one thing with
daycare kids when you look at them they
tend to be
there's some there's good features and
and not so good features
um as that child grows up and goes into
school it really starts to be noticeable
that they are
worried about perfectionism they're
worried about doing everything right
they're worried about they have to get
the a plus the a minus is not good
enough
um that that's how i really when i'm
working with a seven-year-old a
ten-year-old that's what i'm really
looking for is how are they with their
grades how are they with their art how
are they with all the little things that
they should be saying hey look
i drew a fun picture are they saying no
this picture isn't right
there's something wrong with this
picture and i need to burn it and
destroy the evidence that i ever made
this
imperfect thing that's what i'm looking
for when there's attachment
issues okay that's fair so i've been
i've i've talked about this on a
previous podcast but i've been doing
therapy to try and delve into some of
these issues because
i have a three and a half year old and
i've seen some of her
behaviors that have imitated some of my
worst behaviors and i was like oh
my god that is terrible that's terrible
and i need to fix this before you know
it passes on and then
passes on and passes on passes on so i'm
very interested in talking about these
things and i think i grew up in a pretty
like
i think the family part there were
issues but i think it was pretty good
i was very very very very sick if i had
an autoimmune disorder
and i was at the doctor all the time and
that was very
traumatizing especially at a young age
so i think
perhaps some of these what
sound like sound like what you're
describing attachment issues might be
from um being really really really sick
uh what do you think before i've well
without diagnosing you and treating you
from a hypothetical standpoint
um it is possible i i've worked with
people who've
they've had almost perfect home lives
their parents never hit them their
parents were there with them they maybe
didn't talk about feelings very much
but their parents upper class upbringing
they had everything they ever wanted but
something just went wrong
and the child's brain learned something
is wrong with me
no one's going to take care of me i'm
dumped off in this strange place these
bad things keep happening to me
these doctors are poking me with needles
all the time it's not stopping we've
developed kind of like a learned
helplessness
that it's never going to stop no one's
helping me and the brain
can start to say wow so there's
something wrong with me that this is
happening
i better shut down and hide a lot of
these things from other people or hide
who i am how do i feel
i've seen that happen with a number of
things medical things severe medical
things
i've seen um i've seen someone not a
patient but
um someone that i knew personally had a
brain tumor they were born with a brain
tumor and they had to be
locked up and they were also allergic to
most pain killers
so imagine like a one or two year old
being locked up
in a hospital crib and being given
all kinds of brain surgery and all they
could have is something like aspirin
to deal with the pain and they were in
there for weeks and weeks with these
surgeries
and they could still vaguely remember it
as an adult but
so many attachment issues and their
parents were kind their parents were
pretty loving
again didn't much talk about feelings
but they were never abusive
they were upper class gave them
everything they ever wanted
it happens and a lot of people with
attachment issues they say there's no
reason i should be messed up there's no
reason i should have problems i
shouldn't have anxiety
i should be happy look at my life and
and they can get along with most of
their life especially
though once they once they get married
once they have kids
they really start seeing okay some of
these behaviors aren't okay some of
these behaviors are destructive a lot of
um young women like yourself when they
have a child
it completely changes the way that they
think about themselves their
relationships and they say i do not want
this for my child so i need to change
um and i don't know your personal
history or anything but a lot of times
when we have attachment issues we
connect to partners who have attachment
issues
because if we keep up a wall and we
don't want to share our needs or who we
are
we will typically gravitate to someone
else who has the same thing because now
neither one of us is going to push the
boundaries on each other
and we won't share our needs back and
forth we'll just kind of figure it out
and it can become passive aggressive it
can become just empty
a lot of times when women get married
they have a child and with that with
their husband
and they want to change and his outlook
is why would i change this has been
working why are we having this fight
and the wife is is very invested in
changing and fixing it and she cannot
get him to go along with her
i've seen that a lot um that seems to
lead to a lot of divorce
that i worked with because i've done so
many couples counseling
sessions and and um it seems to lead to
a lot of divorce is
one or both has an attachment issue and
usually the wife fixes hers or wants to
and the husband isn't ready to fix it or
just
doesn't understand why it's a problem
hmm
very interesting okay so i'm going to
read a couple of your tweets and then
we're going to go back into these
attachment issue things
so you so two of them 70 of divorces are
initiated by women but as
a couple's therapist i've never seen one
divorce where the husband didn't have
attachment issues
and then the next one every divorcing
couple i ever treated had at least one
partner with attachment issues
divorces between two healthy people just
don't happen
so those are those are very interesting
tweets they were
quite popular on twitter um we just
covered
what attachment issues are um
could we cover what what do attachment
issues look like
in a couple like how could you identify
yeah
attachment issues absolutely and i was
being a little bit absolutist there in
my tweets um
i stand by them yeah yeah maybe there's
maybe there's a couple that doesn't have
an attachment but
by and far by far and away the the major
issue i ever saw as a couple's therapist
was that
because couples could fix any other
problem
if attachment was lined up if they could
have an honest conversation
about needs and about problems and fix
them
great if they had attachment issues it
became impossible to solve any other
problem
that was really what led to that so what
does it look like with an attachment
issue
um one thing that i see a lot is trying
to earn approval
from the partner trying to earn approval
from your partner by doing various
things so with like when i work with
women
um i don't know how friendly family
friendly this podcast is but i'm gonna
talk about sex for a minute
when i work with um with a lot of
partners women with attachment issues
not always but often use sex with their
partner to try to get
approval and love from that partner sex
becomes almost a performative
act where she's more focused on making
sure he's having the time of his life
instead of her having a mutual shared
experience with him
um and i've worked with i've worked with
a lot of women who are in their mid-20s
30s even married women who've never
experienced an orgasm
in their life and usually that's an a
much more advanced level of attachment
issue
where that's just not the point of sex
the point of sex is completely focused
on
how is he doing what is my face doing is
everything perfect in this performance
wow um as far as men
it's built on getting approval and
specifically sexual approval
it's how can i get my wife to have sex
with me it's not
hey it would be great if we as a couple
were sharing a mutual experience that we
were enjoying
it's almost how do i trick my wife and
having sex with me how do i get this
this exploitative transactional
relationship going so i can have sex
uh now he may do ten nice things for her
and he expects her to respond with and
be
so so thrilled that he did the dishes
and walked the dog and took care of the
kids that she is going to suddenly
become spontaneously aroused and leap on
him like a jungle predator
and when she doesn't when she's just
happy like hey cool you're holding on
the fort you're being a great partner
that's wonderful
he gets angry he gets upset he gets
passive aggressive
he says why isn't she meeting my needs
doesn't she care about me
why isn't she decoding the secret hints
that i have sort of dropped that i could
totally deny
at any time and say no i i'm not trying
to get sex from you no i've never tried
to do that
that i could completely deny it any time
why isn't she getting those hints
she just doesn't care about me and he'll
do that for five
years more he'll get more and more
passive-aggressive
women do this often maybe not around sex
but maybe more around
other things that they're looking for
again the thing is
don't ever share your needs don't ever
say i would like blank
please do blank don't ever do that it's
i'm gonna do nice things for you and
you're gonna read
my mind if you really love me you will
know what i want
that's what those attachment pieces look
like in a couple
okay okay just to clarify to the
audience
i definitely do not have that problem
i'm way too disagreeable
to to not not be pushy about what i want
but that's that's that's good to know uh
okay okay so what else do i have okay so
say you find out you're in a
relationship
and one of you has attachment issues how
do you go about fixing that without
it leading to divorce so i've written
two books on this
um one for couples and one for
individuals
really what it looks like to fix
attachments um
it really is a frank conversation it's
education about attachments and what
they are
and then the other person says that's
just how everybody is
and you have to somehow convince them
and say no
people can just have normal loving
conversations where they care about each
other and want to meet each other's
needs
and the other person says no that only
happens on sitcoms and movies
and hallmark movies so part of a big
big chunk of it is just convincing
someone that it can happen and that it
can be real
that that's not how everyone feels
because again that's been their
experience since childhood
and their experience is also that
there's something wrong with them
so if someone else says no that's not
how it is the person's brain says well
then you must be a good person on the
inside but i'm secretly not
that's where that comes in um it really
comes down to learning that people can
love you and what love is and what love
looks like
it comes down to identifying that
transactional relationships can be good
as long as they're based on love and
mutual fulfillment
everything is a transactional
relationship i don't care who you're
talking to
everything is a mutual transactional
relationship now
when i say that everyone gets really
nervous because we're used to an
exploitative
transactional system with capitalism
it's an exploitative transaction system
you want to get as much as you can get
for your dollar
and the other guy is trying to get as
much out of you as he can too that's a
normal that's that's a capitalist
transaction okay that works great for
business
a mutual fulfillment transaction based
on love
that's a marriage i mean you get when
you get in a marriage
you have expectations both of you have
expectations now you can either have
them completely open
every transaction is open about what you
need once you want
or you can have secret transactions
where both of you are holding your cards
to your chest and not sharing with the
other person it's actually wanting from
you and then you have to play a guessing
game and good luck doing that especially
once you have children
but a transactional relationship spreads
beyond that i mean
you can have a transactional
relationship with your best friend in
the entire world
if you think you don't have a
transactional relationship with
expectations try going to their house
and start filling their pockets with
their
your pockets with their personal items
and stealing from them and you'll see
really fast that there are unspoken
expectations in that relationship
as long as you take care of them and
care for them
it's a mutual fulfillment transaction so
fixing attachments is number one
identifying that most people in this
world want mutual fulfillment
transactions based on love
and identifying that you sharing your
needs is actually a show of trust for
the other person
it shows that you trust them and care
for them enough to share your needs
and it allows the other person to feel
good the piece the fundamental piece of
attachment issues is that if you ask for
your needs to be met
the other person is going to reject you
because you are a burden and they will
not want to meet your needs
in reality meeting needs makes us feel
good
meeting someone else's needs makes us
feel really good it does
especially when it's our partner because
then we can feel
like a really good spouse we can feel
like we we are fin
look at me i'm doing everything for you
it's great and i feel good and you're
smiling
i am so happy that you're smiling and
you're meeting my needs in return that's
great
that's the dream if you can do that
that's healthy attachment so convincing
someone that that's even possible
number one number two convincing them
that it's actually good
for the other person to know their needs
so it's it's a gift to the other person
number two number three building a
system of open transactions so that
every trans
action is open number three once a
person does that
i typically have them do it with one
person they trust and their brain says
okay this is a complete fluke let's
never do this again they have to fight
their anxiety the entire time then they
do it and
it's like the worst experience of their
life doing it
starting it and then once they do it
it's great because the other person says
well yeah you want to be open about our
needs and talk yeah that sounds great
i'd love
that too and their brain says that that
this this was unusual this will never
happen again
so they do that a few times and their
brain their neural pathways change away
from don't keep everything a secret
to okay maybe i can share with this one
person then they do it with the second
person
and their brain says don't do this
they're going to hate you and that
person says
yeah that sounds great let's do that and
the brain says okay
maybe it's like 50 50. let's keep the
anxiety
but maybe we could test it and if they
do the third person for some reason
number three the brain clicks and says
fantastic i love this i was so wrong
here's three healthy people who now care
for me i have three
people that love me three people that
love me unconditionally maybe not fully
unconditionally but i know
exactly what they need and expect from
me and how to do it i get feedback when
i do it right i get feedback when i do
it wrong and i get the chance to fix it
and i've tested deep down inside and
they've seen who i am and they haven't
rejected me
they love me even more i have been so
wrong and then at three when they have
three and they've tested it a few times
life changes i've seen anxiety i've seen
people come in with ptsd
and panic attacks and daily constant
anxiety and struggling
over and over with these episodic
depressions where they've been on
medications and they haven't worked
where it's been just this brutal life
for them
and they come in and number one i teach
them progressive muscle relaxation to
bring that anxiety down
just enough so that they can start
having these conversations
um some people take anxiety medication
instead
whatever works whatever gets you there
um once they have that first
conversation
things start changing i've had couples
come in where one of them has just had
to fare
and they both have attachment issues we
work together for
let's say two three weeks three weeks
and they
they consistently do this and they are
already reporting greater happiness
a month after an affair greater
happiness than they did as newlyweds
or even before getting married when they
were dating it can be that fast i have
seen people turn their life around from
panic attacks three days a week
to zero panic attacks their anxiety is
maybe two out of ten
every day depression is gone and they're
reporting greater life satisfaction than
they've ever known in their life i've
had that happen in three or four weeks
attachment wow is everything it's
everything
so you think if you're in a like a
marriage and somebody has an affair that
there's a way
back from that absolutely it
well it really depends on the attachment
uh with both people the affairs that i
see i almost never see affairs
almost never see any extended kind of
affairs
outside of someone having an attachment
issue that usually is
um women always ask why did he have an
affair
usually because he has the attachment
issue and he
is too afraid to ask his wife for sex so
he
spends 10 years trying to win sex from
her and eventually the marriage gets
soured because he's passive aggressive
and mean all the time to her
for not having sex with him so he then
goes out and finds someone to have sex
with
because he feels like the good person
now i have done so many good things for
you
you have never reciprocated i am the
good person this is also why people with
attachment issues tend to pick someone
who has a lot of other issues because
it's really easy to read that person and
say
look at all the nice things i can do for
you and take care of you and win your
love and win sex from you based on
all the things i take care of you for
that's where affairs tend to happen
and then coming back from those affairs
the most successful
recoveries from affairs that i see is
when we talk about attachment
and one or both partners says holy crap
that's me
that's why all this happened and then
both partners did they do they ever say
holy crap that's you
sometimes yeah oh yeah if if one of them
doesn't have an attachment issue they
look at the other one and say
this is you and then the pieces start
clicking into place
and then they can say okay what you did
wasn't malicious you really believed
this was the only way for you to act
i don't want that and i'm now i hope you
don't realize
you realize you don't want that the way
that that relationship is fixed
is by the person who had the affair
coming back in and saying
these are all the behaviors from my
attachment issues these are the new
behaviors i'm going to do that will show
you i don't have those attachment issues
anymore all the open transactions
open sharing of needs everything i will
do all of that consistently
and by doing that that will prove that
you can trust me again i have seen
i've seen let's say wives um in in
affairs in marriages where there's an
affair
i've seen the wife come in and say i
don't know that i can ever
trust you again and he fixes his
attachment issues
and within a couple of weeks she's
reporting more trust in him than she's
ever had in the marriage
ever even before the affair even at the
beginning of the marriage it was kind of
like well he's never done
anything wrong so i guess i'll trust him
to you are proving to me that you are
consistently
healthily attached to me and i know that
you will never have an affair because we
are so tight and so open
that we would see it coming 10 miles
away that's when marriages can get fixed
from affairs
and that's also how trust is rebuilt in
the marriage is when you have those
behaviors you have to actively rebuild
those
those that trust with healthy attachment
attachment is everything
everything wow you're so full of
information
i don't think i've ever learned about
that that's so fascinating i've been
i think i was so ill for so long that i
kind of just i was like this is a
serious problem
like what's going on here is a serious
problem and all those psychological
techniques
and different ways of thinking are not
going to work which was true
but once i got rid of the like horrible
disorders
there's a lot there's a lot you can do
with like psychological techniques and
changing the way you think and all these
natural things that
so much a lot of the medical community
is not aware of you know if you
get me going i'm one i'm one of the few
really people in the united states
that's talking about attachment
um dr robert glover is another one he's
a genius
his works are incredible um but as far
as
looking at attachments in adults very
rare
i'm one of the few people talking about
it really like this openly
because our diagnostic statistics manual
specifies that
attachment disorders only happen in
childhood and that attachment disorders
must grow up into conduct disorders and
must grow up into personality disorders
so someone can have it and that has to
be treated with drugs
personality personality disorders you
can't even a lot of times they say ah
you can't even really treat it yeah
you know we have we have things for
borderline personality disorder
dialectical behavior
therapy and stuff like that but um it
doesn't have to be that extreme you can
just have broken attachment
and very few people are talking about
that but if you get me on any
show me you know show me bipolar i tell
people if you have in childhood
and you are struggling with attachment
from
from birth or from three five whatever
it is
you're struggling with attachment and
you're struggling struggling struggling
and you really believe that if you show
people who you are they will reject you
and that they won't love you or they
won't take care of you they won't
protect you
whatever it might be then you believe
there's something wrong with you deep
down
you can become very closed off and say
i'm not going to share
what i want or you can become very
aggressive and say i have to
force you to give me what i want or you
can even switch some of those later on
but that's going to build anxiety
generalized anxiety disorder really
kicks in and starts taking off i've
treated
11 year olds with generalized anxiety
disorder full-on disorders
that anxiety starts growing growing
growing until you're 12
13 14 15 and then your brain says so
many bad things
keep happening and your brain says just
crank the anxiety up it's my fault
i wasn't smart enough i didn't figure
out how to fix it i whatever it is just
crank the anxiety up and up and up and
up
by the time you hit 14 15 16 earlier
sometimes
your brain says bad things keep
happening to me and i'm worrying as much
as i can and i've given up so many
things just to keep worrying
there's just no hope and we develop
learned helplessness and depression
kicks in
male depression is typically focused on
having a mission and being able to
accomplish that mission
female depression is typically focused
on being loved and being useful to the
people that you love
just generalized um generalizations
there
they'll get me in trouble i'm sure with
social media hi everyone
once that depression starts kicking in
it grows and grows and grows
and then when bad things happen your
brain says there's no hope i can't
overcome this so we start developing
panic attacks
there's nothing i can do your limbic
system kicks on
the little brain when you're two years
old and your brain thinks people are
gonna abandon you
let's ten thousand years ago our
neolithic brains
ten thousand years ago our brains are
equipped to say if someone abandons me
when i'm two
bears will eat me in the forest and i
will starve to death so it connects
abandonment and rejection with death and
your limbic system clicks in every time
you're afraid you're going to be
abandoned
rejected whatever it might be so we have
these massive anxiety attacks
every time we feel like people are going
to leave us or hurt us or reject us
and with that depression kicked in we
believe there's nothing we can do about
it so we have these
life or death struggles um so attachment
and um
attachment leads straight to those those
panic attacks
eventually when you don't when your
panic attacks aren't doing anything for
you
nothing is working and bad things keep
happening
well borderline personality or not
borderline um
that is one growth um blanking bipolar
bipolar disorder bipolar one and bipolar
two now the difference
is um manic and hypomanic it's how hard
you go um
i always say bipolar one is is type one
is the hardest one go big or go home
um bipolar kicks in
now why does it kick in well what does
it do
it gives you a moment of rest from all
the worrying and all the frustration
and all the terror about what people
will think of you and you have these
manic episodes or hypomanic where you
forget about all the consequences your
brain clicks off
the part that worries about consequences
and just says
i'm going to do what feels good
typically there's different features
there's paranoid and
there's all kinds of things um but it
clicks those pieces off and says i'm
just gonna
i'm gonna do what feels really good for
me and that can land you in the hospital
that can land you in jail that can land
you in all kinds of things because what
really feels good for you regardless
what consequences
sometimes is not a great thing
especially if you've built up a lifetime
of repressing your needs and your
thoughts and your feelings
can really get some ugly places um but
but that
that's a feature above bipolar people
always think how do i stop bipolar well
what is it accomplishing
it's letting you feel what you really
feel and it's giving you brief
moments of happiness that you otherwise
would never feel that's why when people
start medicating with people with
bipolar they say
i kind of missed the episodes because
those were the only times i ever felt
happy
i hear that all the time when i work
with people who are medicated for
bipolar
um that's just one that's one night it's
one feature of it is it takes care of
you
the other thing is you could have a
seizure if you go into that level i've
seen a lot of i've seen a lot of weird
connections with bipolar and seizures
um i don't know if there's research to
connect that but just anecdotally in my
practice but is that people who are
medicated
with seizures yeah is that people is
that bipolar people who are medicated
and then it can be i'm not saying this
i'm not saying the medication causes it
i'm saying um i had a seizure from
from from medication
here's the way here's my my completely
outside of my scope of practice i'm not
a medical provider
um but what i have seen is because i go
into it with evolutionary psychology
what purpose does bipolar serve
when you are so stressed and so
miserable and
so unhappy and there's nothing you can
do about it
your brain says i'm either going to kill
myself and have a seizure and explode
because i can't handle it
or i'm going to click it off and have a
good time now if you start medicating
that and your brain says just have a
bipolar episode just have a bipolar
episode it'll get rid of the stress
when you can't do that i've seen a lot
of people have
have seizures because their brain just
can't handle the emotional overload
anymore
i'd love to see research on that and see
if i'm right or wrong i could be wrong
but i've seen so many people with
bipolar have seizures
during times of high stress when they
can't have
yeah i guess it is when they're
medicated when they can't have an
episode they have a seizure instead
that's their way their brains way of
saying i can't handle this anymore i'm
checking out
um sounds like the bipolar manic
episodes are protecting you from
seizures they're protecting you from
suicide or they're protecting you from
something
so yeah that's a very interesting way of
thinking about it
i was so i was diagnosed with bipolar
type two
in my in my teens years major depressive
disorder when i was 12.
um and and that actually i managed to
get that under control with diet so i
think a lot of it was an inflammatory
response but one of the medications i
took
triggered a seizure i thought so i
stopped taking that medication and i
didn't have that problem anymore but i
full-on had a like full grand mal
seizure
which was exciting yeah although um
it actually i've looked into this a
little bit because they use
you can you can get treated um with
shock therapy right that rattles up your
brain a bit
and kind of acts like a seizure yeah and
some people
say that helps although it can also
really really not help
but um i i did feel better after the
seizure
which was strange definitely well um
think of what happens your brain
completely
shuts down what it's doing it switches
up its chemicals
and it stops worrying about everything
you've been worrying about
that's a lot of reason i think that
people with bipolar also use
drugs is it completely disrupts
everything you've been worrying about
and then when you come out of that
when you wake up with a hangover or
whatever it might be your brain says
wow i haven't been worrying about
everything for all this time
i feel pretty good and then you start
developing all those worries all over
again and then you have another binge
then you have another binge then you
have another binge
same with manic episodes maybe same with
seizures i don't know it'd be great to
see research on that
um i do know i do know that
self-mutilation and self-harm that's the
mechanism that's being used
is because your brain your hind brain
your left brain
logic your right brain emotion your
bright brain to have that emotional
storm
sucks the energy off the left brain and
diminishes your logical response so you
have these emotional storms
but you can't logic your way out of
feelings even if it's completely
irrational you can't even identify that
it's totally irrational
you can't calm yourself down the third
the the hind brain
if your body is an intense physical
discomfort
like cutting like push-ups like running
a marathon something intense
but the hind brain says something's
happening with my body and it's not
right i need to figure it out unless it
before it kills me
diminishes the emotional brain restores
that energy back to the logical side of
the brain and suddenly you feel better
and you
you feel all this emotional relief
cutting activates that because you're
literally cutting your flesh
um running activates that runner's high
things like that progressive muscle
relaxation is one that i teach
very very effective but it has to be
prolonged and intense this is one reason
also people feel so good after doing
yoga
is because it's a prolonged intense
physical discomfort a lot of people with
mental health
issues anxiety attachment issues love
yoga
and they don't know why that's why it's
activating that um
like that kind of intense exercise too
don't you get kind of an opiate response
from the pain yeah there's all kinds of
good things that happen there
um but it disrupts what what you were
worrying about your brain stops
stops the emotional response drains it
sometimes totally zero
and then you have to slowly build that
emotional anxiety back up over the next
couple of days or hours or whatever it
might be for the person
but i would expect that seizures would
probably serve the same purpose
because you completely stops your brain
from thinking about what it was upset
about
manic episodes same thing your brain
stops worrying about everything it was
worried about
alcohol binges heroine binges whatever
it might be
stops the brain from worrying about
attachment issues again
let's look at ten thousand years ago if
you're if if your brain really says
everyone hates me there's something
wrong with me i shouldn't be around
people and if they see me they'll spit
on me and reject me your brain says well
then i'm gonna be living on the outside
of the village
yeah and bears are gonna kill me i'm
gonna die so of course you're anxious
all the time
of course you have depression of course
you feel like you're going to die
because back then you would
um when you fix that when you fix the
attachment all these things go away i've
seen people with bipolar
go it goes away when they fix their
attachment issues
100 goes away so they don't have any
episodes anymore and i'm talking
years after the fact they they still
haven't had a bipolar thing
um yeah attachment everything big time
there's work over in i think it was
finland
could be wrong but they they took
patients with schizophrenia
and they did they gave them zero
medication and they
brought them into a care facility with
their families and gave
family therapy to the entire family to
unify them and heal those bonds
and what they found was when they did
that those people
had with zero medication had
vastly diminished severity on their
psycho their psychotic episodes
um they were less frequent and everyone
could come together and help them manage
them so their symptoms diminished and
became
better managed than with medication here
in the united states
looking at attachment that's crazy
attachment with schizophrenia
yeah that's that's amazing that's
amazing i'm not a huge
people on my podcast no i'm not a huge
fan of medication it didn't work for
like it full-on just didn't work it
initially worked
then it didn't work then i got way worse
then i got better
with diet and started figuring my head
out and i got off of it and it
[ __ ] me for like two and a half years
i was completely [ __ ]
like thanks for telling me that before i
went on it when i was 12.
so yeah not withdrawals
yeah sorry i'll interrupt you real quick
but i i agree with you with medication
100 it is a useful tool for helping you
diminish your emotional response
so that you can then go out and do the
work that will actually short term
yeah exactly that's what that's what it
should most likely be used for in most
cases
um we just throw people on it just call
it good we say oh you're anxious you're
crushingly anxious and you think no one
will ever love you
take this anxiety pill you'll probably
be fine just take it every day for the
rest of your life and the withdrawals
will be absolutely terrible if you ever
try to come off
yeah and we'll tell you it's just your
underlying disorder rather than telling
you it's withdrawal
lovely not very impressed i just had
i just had a couple of doctors on that
did like mad in america
or it was a pharmacist and a doctor and
we talked a little bit about the
withdrawal that can come with
like psych medications that people are
not aware of
um stop that yeah big time
okay that was a lot of information thank
you very much for that
absolutely i'm just gonna throw some
like easier
easier questions sure okay okay this is
a good one
if you're male is being vulnerable to
your female
partner a good idea or is that a turn
off
i get that all the time all the time um
the answer is no there's a way to be
never be vulnerable in any way not ever
no so man
this is such a big topic um
you have to be you have to be vulnerable
to your female partner
because female long-term sex drive is
based on emotional intimacy
so you have to have some vulnerability
with your female partner
if you are not vulnerable to her at all
you are sending the message to her that
she is immediately replaceable that you
are not investing in her
and that she should not have sex with
you that's the message you're sending
now how do you be vulnerable to her
because men with attachment issues
again men with attachment issues think
that being vulnerable to her means
throwing himself at her feet sobbing
uncontrollably telling her how
miserable he is and then begging her to
please have sex with him while he's
crying
that's what they think i say when they
should be to be vulnerable
not the case um you could probably
attest that that would not be sexy in a
male partner you wouldn't want a husband
that does that
but you also do want to know women also
do want to know what their husband is
thinking
they want to know what their husband
wants they want to know when he's
struggling so that they can help him
because again
female depression is typically based
around
feeling unloved and feeling useless to
the people she loves so women are
happiest when they are loved
and feel loved and when they feel useful
to the people that they love so if you
never share any vulnerability of any
kind with your wife you
are making her miserable and you are
telling her that you don't trust her
enough to help you with those problems
so
what i tell men is this learn to be
vulnerable to your wife in a way that is
productive and builds her respect for
you
and also gives her a chance to help you
what that looks like is having good
attachment um but it also looks like
going to her and saying hey
i'm having this frustration share the
feeling you're having share share the
share the pur show the problem share the
feeling you're having about the problem
share the solution you have probably
already thought of and then
say before i do this can you tell me
anything that i you think i'm missing is
there anything else in addition to this
that i should pay attention to
because men's brains our brains are
larger sorry
uh they're larger but that makes them
slower
we can't connect the different regions
very well so if you tell a guy
here's a problem he's going to grab a
hammer and solve that problem
not thinking about all the other
problems that his solution is going to
cause
a woman's brain is two-thirds the size
but it's very interconnected rapidly
and very relational and will say okay if
you do that here's
all these additional problems that will
come up here's these additional effects
it will impact your relationship with
this person
it will change this person this person
over here will have this feeling so
you're going to have to do that
my wife's brain when i bring her a
problem and say i don't say
solve this for me because that's not how
her brain works she doesn't want me
running to her like i'm like
she's my mom and saying please solve
this for me she likes it when i come to
her and say
this is driving me up the wall here's
what i think i'm going to do about it
do you think i'm missing anything there
does that sound like a good decent
solution
to you or or is something is there
something there i'm not seeing and she
will
come up with some astounding insights
about well that that could affect this
over here so have you thought about just
just changing your approach a little bit
and i say that's a great idea thank you
for sharing
that with me and then i go out and do it
same thing that's the same way we make
decisions in
our marriage she brings problems to me i
find the solution because that's
male brain we're a solution machine and
then i say here's the solution i think
might work
and she picks it apart and says here's
all the problems with it
let's do it this way and then we come up
with a decision i say okay
that's what we're doing um that's the
way that works that's the way that
most not all but most neurotypical male
and female pairings work
it's the same way with being vulnerable
if you are not doing that with your wife
the message you're sending is that she's
not worth
sharing problems with that's how female
communication works that's why women
process feelings out loud to each other
i trust you i trust you to know my
problems and not use them against me
i think that you are valuable and wise
and insightful and you will help me
solve that problem
and i'm invested in you so i'm going to
stay around with you for a while and
build our relationship bill start based
on these things if you're not
if you're if you're being vulnerable to
your wife you're sending good messages
if you're being not vulnerable ever to
your wife and letting her help you
you are sending the opposite messages
i'm not going to be around i'm going to
find the next 20 year old blonde woman
who walks by and i'm going to follow her
instead because
i don't really care much about you that
will shut a female sex drive down in
marriage when i see sexless marriages
it's often either the husband is not
being vulnerable at all or he's being
so crushingly insecure with attachment
issues that she doesn't respect him at
all
so it's one of the two usually it's
always attachment
wow this is so interesting you've said
you
you've written like 20 books i've
written 20 books total
i write fiction i've written short yeah
so i've written two psychology books um
and there are a hundred pages if you
listen to the audio books they're two
hours
i wanted to make pamphlets for people
basically dr robert glover wrote this
beautiful like 200 300 word
300 page book called no more mr nice guy
and i loved it and i said
yeah it's great none of my patients will
ever read this so let me take my own
spin on some of this information some of
the things that i've been percolating
and make a 100 page pamphlet and hand it
to them and at the end of the book it
tells them to go read dr robert glover's
book
so i wrote a book called exhausted wives
bewildered husbands
because that's the pairing i see the
wife is exhausted from dealing with all
the problems and the husband is confused
about why there are even problems in the
first place
i wrote that book for couples for with
attachments and it walks through how to
fix them
i wrote another book called slaying your
fear it's got a dude on a cover stabbing
this demon with like a cool sword
um and that is a book for individuals
with a
it's like a five or six step process of
fixing attachment problems
the first quarter of the book is what
are attachment problems second quarter
of the book
is what do attachment problems look like
in adults and how do they form in
children
and the last half of the book is just 50
pages of here's what you do to fix
attachment issues
i have handed those books out at
seminars i've held seminars and spoken
to
a range of healthcare professionals
teaching them that method i have
therapists across america right now that
are using my method and checking in with
me working with their patients
signed releases and everything so i can
work with them i'm running that program
right now really good and it's achieving
results i'm talking
suicidal suicidal like 10 year olds and
parents coming in with a suicidal 10
year old and saying how do we fix this
we need to fix this so bad and no one no
one seems to know how to fix it
and they run my program and it fixes not
only the problem with that child but
with the whole family because
attachment is very generational so yeah
those two books there are 100 pages
they're i think they're like five bucks
for the
the audiobook i try to make them as
cheap as possible for people because i
just want people to get
help i just want people to get better
this country
since world war one attachment has
broken down generationally and i won't
go into this super long but
world war one was the beginning of
broken generational attachment here in
the west
it has progressed with every single
generation it's got worse
every generation has been shaped by it
down to the current one um
if we can fix attachment issues 99 of
our problems as in the west will go away
and be healed because we'll be able to
fix them we cannot fix them until we fix
our generational attachment problems
nothing will ever work
wow okay so how do you
okay say me me with scarlett and
to give you a bit of a background like
scarlet's doing amazingly well
good like 95 of the time she's happy
she sleeps pretty well and like
our house is full of love so like things
are going well but then
i've noticed specifically if i get upset
about something and then i don't say
anything
she'll freak out and i'll be like oh my
god she's just
showing all the emotion i have stuffed
inside of me now i have to go like have
a cry so that she can stop worrying
so that that's what i've been focused on
but it's like it's a small proportion of
our
of like of any issues however i am
trying to learn
how to bring her up in a world so that
she's aware of her emotions and how to
navigate them
so for for people who have kids do you
have suggestions on how
they should either treat or teach their
children to be aware of
attachment issues yeah oh most
definitely again none of this is
healthcare advice and i'm not i can't do
therapy for you but i will give
generalizations of what i
personally think um i have to add that
disclaimer
man kids again when they're that small
and if they already have some attachment
pieces
um if there's divorce if there's day
care if there's whatever there could be
um their little brains think that
everything is about them
so if mom is upset if mama's depressed
they can they can almost smell it like
there's been working human pheromones
that we might be able to smell it
but they can just tell because they are
hardwired to pay very
disturbingly close attention to other
people's moods
and then they blame themself and they
say you're upset it must be my fault
life is over i'm going to die the bears
are going you're going to kick me out
the bears are going to come eat me
um so what i tell people is don't hide
things from your kids
like you don't have to give them the
graphic details of all kinds of stuff
but
explain to your kids how are they going
to learn about attachment and about
about emotions about how to manage
emotions about how to problem solve
emotions
about how people care how are they going
to do that if we don't model it for them
and walk them through it step by step
one great thing one great thing that i
adapt from a lot
of the autism community
is people with autism basically need an
instruction manual on human interaction
what are you doing why are you doing it
why are you blinking that way why are
you breathing that way why are you using
those words
they need that because they they are
fundamentally a brain is is
has shifted so they aren't those things
aren't innate to them like it might be
to a neurotypical person
children with attachment disorders i i
basically say treat them very much like
someone with autism
explain it to that degree break down
things for them in
excruciating detail with emotions
because they believe it's their fault
explain why you are feeling what you're
feeling talk them through it
okay um and oftentimes they're hardwired
not to trust you
or not if you say just ask me if you
have questions they will probably never
ask you
um because they assume the quest the
answer is it's their fault
so going to them being extremely
proactive can be very helpful
one thing i work with when i work with
therapists who go out and and use my
program
with parents who have children who have
attachment issues and the parents might
also have attachment issues
is to have proactive conversations about
the features of attachment and say do
you do you ever worry that i'm going to
leave you
do you ever worry that you're not good
enough do you ever worry that there's
something wrong with you
do you worry that you know all these all
these questions um
all those thoughts and healings and and
the child will almost always say no
even if they do because they don't want
you to know that there's something wrong
with them
um it's scary to have an authority
figure
in your life and sometimes parent if you
have an attachment disorder or not
disorder if you have attachment issues
um
non-clinical non-diagnose if you have
those issues your parent becomes an
authority figure
versus a comfort figure if you have
those it can be very difficult to admit
to them that you have problems
so what i should have parents do
is share with them your experience of
attachment share with them that you
always had those fears do you ever worry
that people will
find out who you really are on the
inside and then leave you because i
always
used to worry about that so much and
here's what i did to fix it and here's
how here's what i've learned
um man what a great conversation to have
with your child because even if they
don't have attachment issues
they get to know you and if you have
attachment issues and you display
them and that child sees them they will
have no idea what you're doing or why
you can walk them through it then it
starts to logically make sense oh
mom is anxious because mom hasn't shared
her feelings
so i need to go here's what i can do to
go help mom with her attachment issues
and i'm not talking putting it on your
child as your therapist
i'm talking forming a healthy loving
mutual fulfillment bond
with that child so they understand you
so that when they grow up and have a
spouse
they learn how to emotionally take care
of that spouse also not
not if their spouse has attachment
issues that's one thing but
you're raising your children not to be
children you're raising your children to
be 30 years old you're raising your
children to be 50 years old
that's really the view so i tell people
if your child is having issues
what do you want them to look like when
they're 50 and how do you want them to
handle things when they're 50 those
emotional struggles
educate them educate them and then train
them
in those processes so they will do them
by instinct when they're 50.
have those conversations if if we're
upset if um
how should i say this if a mom is upset
the child will blame themself
if the mom doesn't explain why she's
upset the child will blame himself
if the mom goes in the other room and
manages her feelings and then comes back
and feels better the child will assume
that something has changed so that the
mom is no longer mad at the child
that's how i see that usually play out
the child doesn't say wow mom's doing
great it must have just been a fluke
the child says i don't know what i did
to make mom happy but she's happy so i
better try to figure out what i did to
make her happy
um that's just what it didn't happen and
again saying that's you good information
i've seen that all the time i i think
that makes sense like i can remember
like family arguments and i can remember
like being a kid
and if there was any anger in any member
of the family
as a kid i can remember being like what
i do how do i make it better
and then so yeah that that totally makes
sense with
with scarlett i've been just being vocal
about that vocal about why i'm feeling
like i've been
learning to be like you know i'm upset
something happened she's like three and
a half like i can't i can't explain it
thoroughly
but i'm like something happened at work
it's not you
i need to have a cry when i have a cry
i'll feel better
you can give me a hug if you want to
give me a hug but yeah
that kind of thing um but it we are like
i
i am anyway i am hardwired to be like oh
no
i'm you know feeling miserable better
just like
pretend everything's normal and deal
with it later and then that just stinks
up the atmosphere
yeah because there's there's a time and
a place to deal with those feelings but
yeah if if we're shutting down saying no
one wants to put up with my crap
no one's going to help me it's just me i
got to muscle through it on my own
yes people around you can still tell
like you can't hide it that well yes and
with women
if you're having a feeling and another
woman identifies that you're having a
feeling
and asks you about it and says i want to
help you with it how do i help you and
you say
screw you i'm not telling you anything
get away from me you can't help me
shut up that sounds the wrong message
yeah so it's if you open up again female
female female everything is built on
emotional intimacy
with with relationships their female
relationships are typically built on
emotional intimacy um and mutual why
don't you what
okay so why don't we get into that a
little bit what do you mean by like what
is emotional intimacy
emotional intimacy is the expectation
that you can be open
and safe with the other person you can
share whatever you need that your needs
will
either be met or be acknowledged and
that you will find you will work
together as a team to meet both of your
needs
and that there will be no harsh anger
and judgment just for feelings or needs
and that if you
trust yes trust is another word for
emotional intimacy
especially the female variation of trust
is based on emotional intimacy very much
trust
um sex long-term sex driving a marriage
is based on emotional intimacy
everything is based on that it's do i do
you
trust me enough to come to me share your
needs
share when you're upset and trust me to
help you
and commiserate with you and bond with
you and then we are closer than ever
before
so the next time something happens we'll
do it again and we'll do it again and
again and our whole life will be built
on every time one of us has a need the
other one will help fix it
especially emotionally that's emotional
intimacy and if you have that
so much happiness and if you don't have
that it's like starving to death
wow this is fascinating okay
i only have like six more minutes i'm
gonna pick one of these i might have to
have you back on because that was
that this is this is great thank you
that would be great i'd love to i'll
i'll read the books first so i'll be
less of a noob
when i start but this is fantastic okay
okay okay last question let's how do you
know
when you're in a relationship that's not
going to work like when do you sort it
out and when do you run
what i tell people is this if you fix
your attachment
and the other person does not fix their
attachment and is not willing to open up
and fix it
that relationship is doomed not because
the other person will destroy it but
because you will not tolerate it anymore
once you realize that there's that you
you've been living here in the desert
but just over that hill is this lush
green land of
love and fulfillment and emotional
intimacy and it's right there
and this person chooses never to look
over that hill and demands that you stay
with them in the desert
that relationship is just doomed whether
it's a marriage whether it's a
friendship
even if it's mother and father and child
no relationship can survive while one
person is educated about attachment
and has this whole plan for healthy
attachment in their life and the other
person
absolutely refuses to go over that hill
and have healthy attachment you just
can't stand to be around that person
it's it's miserable if you're in a
partnership with them you can't raise
children with them because
that's often why divorces happen it's
because the wife fixes her attachment
and says look at this green land i want
our children raised here and the husband
says
the whole world is desert what do you
mean why are you causing a problem
we're staying here in the desert we're
going to barely survive together as a
family
and the wife sees the husband dragging
the kids into the desert
and ends the marriage at 10 15 20 years
sometimes whatever it might be
because she wants her children have as
much of this green land as possible
that's when i see that it's it's all the
attachment if both people have healthy
attachment
then you guys say here's my need what's
your needle that's your need okay
how can we meet each other's needs and
make sure that this is a mutual
fulfilling relationship you can
fix just about any problem if you both
have healthy attachment
it's when one of you absolutely refuses
will not open up
will not trust the other one will not
share those needs and will continue to
give 10 nice things to you with strings
attached demanding that you read their
mind
and meet their needs it's impossible to
have a relationship like that
that's when i see that the divorces
happen right there
okay that last last question
if somebody's in that situation is it
actually better to get a divorce
from a person who won't fix attachment
issues than to stay
if you have kids
that's a million dollar question um
i don't know that i can answer if the
divorce itself is better or not
i think that in that case though divorce
is usually inevitable
because the person with attachment will
drive the other person in with with bad
attachment
insane by demanding they open up and
demanding that they connect and that
will kick the other person's limbic
system their fight or flight into
overdrive because they're
they've got this wall up divorce is
almost inevitable at that point
because they just can't function and
what i tell people when they come in and
ask me adam should i get a divorce my
partner won't change
what i tell them is would you rather
have your child
grow up in a completely broken household
where you are both
okay with how broken it is or do you
need to send a message to your child
that you are willing to fight for
healthy love and truth
regardless of where that takes you
that's really that question
yes that's really where that comes down
yeah yeah fair fair enough okay if
people don't follow you and would like
to follow you where can they find you
online
so i am at the prometheus on twitter
which was a funny name i made up
my friend my buddy made up for me
actually like seven
eight years ago and now here i am with a
big following and people ask me why you
have such a
funny twitter name um i am at adam i'm
just adam lanesmith.com
um i write books and i go by my middle
name because you don't want to be an
author named adam smith because no one
will ever find
you on amazon um so adam lanesmith.com
if you want to send hate mail send it
there and
that's really it find me there again my
books are on amazon adam lane smith
slaying your fear is the number one book
if anyone wants information about
attachment i've poured everything into
slaying your fear
i throw it at people when they come in
my office and say please read this 100
page book
it will prime you for everything that we
need to talk about and most people don't
read it so i give them the whole spiel
anyway during therapy so
okay fantastic thank you very much for
coming on
thank you for having me
[Music]
you